hello everyone we are here for another
design review for version 13.2 this is
about control systems
um and uh
what's that
system modeling it's more system
modeling and mostly system modeling
can I make a procedural Point could we
simply combine these next few meetings
rather than having to switch
uh
switch streams here we have three design
reviews all next to each other could we
simply arrange for the people who are
relevant to come in when we get to the
next design review yes we can make that
happen the
um I just tag this as a general version
13.2 design review because it's just a
whole lot of different stuff here
all right
um
so as a as a preamble
oh wait a minute we haven't started yet
right no no we will we're rolling we're
talking about system modeling yep
go ahead
um you know as a preamble uh we're
improving the integration between system
modeling and other parts of the system
and workflows great
okay
so um maybe we should start at the
bottom of the first part here so we've
changed the
um
that's not so much to say there but but
if you look at the icon there
this thing so that's a com yeah so
that's a component that has you know
that represents a
it's a component but it's a slightly
complicated component so when you press
the plus you go from icon to the diagram
View
and now you can also get information
which was very hard to get before okay
question that that icon doesn't look
consistent with our other icons of the
same type it's similar but not the same
and also what it's doing is not the same
as what normally happens with an I can
we make sure that that's consistent
what you know it's it's supposed to go
to the website because we don't have
this documentation well then what the
hell is it doing here
um so if you have similar monitor
installed it goes to documentation
system monitor
but it's it's actually going to a
website okay it's actually going to a
website
okay but but so there were many
practical problems here okay that took
way too long it's really going to take
why did it take so long
it's just going to a website it should
be a trivial lookup right because that
the mapping to this is Trivial so why
did it take so long it took like 15
seconds there
yeah it was probably loading the system
modeling functionality
yeah
so and functionality that needs to load
to just go to documentation I don't
understand that
well you need to look up what this page
is which the system model of
functionality knows yeah but that page I
can I don't need anything fancy look at
it I'm just reading off the the you know
I don't need to spend 15 seconds to load
the functionality to tell me how to put
a prefix in front of that URL
because that's all it did
am I making sense
do you understand what I'm saying
yes it's just a it's just something
wrong okay it should be fixed
right if you have a user interface
element like this it should work
immediately
now we'll see if that's possible
uh
okay I mean it's obviously possible with
infinite amounts of work but I'm just
saying it looks to me like this thing
should just be opening a URL where it
determines the URL from this
now maybe it's trying to look around to
see whether you've got System model
installed but there may be a faster way
to do that
it's just the engineering no I I
I can't answer for all possible cases in
this case what you saw is that but it
could be that it's a component that you
or someone else has developed and
there's still documentation that it
should find fine
system or is it doing something
completely different
completely different that's nothing to
do with a packet system shouldn't it use
the packlet system
no why not
um
because that's a really good way to to
do this to make sure that there are
components loaded that it's you know
cached all that kind of stuff I mean
there's obviously a new system so the
caching
the the caching but the performance side
and caching has not happened it happened
a little bit this time but it requires
much deeper integration within the
system modeler team and several other
projects I would like to make the
suggestion that System model consider
using packlets since packlets are now a
fairly mature technology and they solve
these problems of of you know loading
stuff in and and so on
rather than having a separate custom
mechanism which is clearly much harder
to maintain so just a point I don't
understand how packets play a role
because the library that we use here it
comes in the layout
so why do I need a packlet what's the
package what were you loading if you
spent 15 seconds loading something
you're loading something
so otherwise you know there's a mystery
15 seconds that I was waiting to get to
that documentation you said it was
loading something if it's loading
something packlets are relevant if it
wasn't loading anything yeah I mean it
already has the library the packet would
add additional time to download it did
something in those 15 seconds we don't
know what it was no it loads the system
on the Kernel
it loads it from disk into memory is
that right yeah yeah okay well then why
don't why didn't I see the standard blue
box that's a progress box saying I'm
starting the system model a kernel
it probably should okay fine if it
showed that I'm a happy person right
okay and that box by the way needs to be
standardized without other it is
standard we we've already transitioned
that we did that in 13 Watts traffic
okay so I'm just saying this isn't quite
right please make sure that it's
consistent with our other information
boxes
yeah here's one this one
I thought it is the same well it doesn't
look I don't know it doesn't seem quite
it is the same I think we it doesn't
have a mouse though okay I don't know it
doesn't look quite right to me
but and I'm surprised this one doesn't
have a mouse over but doesn't okay I
mean I wanted question mark but we
changed it to an i because that's what
we used elsewhere fine
okay all right anyway so what were you
showing here you were showing
I'm just showing that that just the fit
and finish of using these have gone up
right you know you could find
information because you needed to know
to go to a website and things like that
no that's great that's definitely an
improvement I I would just like to
suggest that design take crack at this I
think this could be a little bit better
I I'm you know
I know what it is but you know whatever
I see
these you know giant PLM like you know
systems and even the fanciest places
there's a certain
I don't know what you know rough
humanness to the design I you know
whether it's our stuff or whether it's
whether it's other
you know kinds of engineering
presentations and maybe I'm just maybe
my aesthetic is just wrong
um but it it feels like it could be a
bit more elegant just just the Chrome
here yeah
I mean sure
when you say Graphics design you mean
Jeremy yes I do what is this saying out
98 in a previous session
the heck
what is that
well I saw a mouse over
I saw a mouse
but it said out 98 in a previous session
in a weird font anybody else see it that
was it um local time oh there it is what
is that
Kristen I think that's for you to go
figure out what an earth what is that
that might be something to do with
percent modernization
okay I have a screenshot of it and send
it to John fultz and ask him on Earth it
is
I mean it's cool it just isn't a very
nice font
all right let's keep going yeah so do I
move upwards back up here yeah yeah
let's move upwards
uh
that was the thing we just went through
um
System model plot I it's not worth going
into unless I can show you a big
notebook of it uh so system
do you want a shot I mean I don't have
any I need sort of a big set of
benchmarks and I don't have them to show
you but if I did System model plot of
this puppy here
yeah it's a component you can't simulate
it but if I might say so that is not an
elegant set of error messages for that
case
we should improve that but if you know
it's a component you can't simulate just
say it in an exit don't produce all this
crud
yeah
okay yep um
but
I mean I absolutely hate the system
model examples thing but I guess I know
I really hate it and I really hate the
inconsistency with everything I really
hate this really hate it
let's have that discussion somewhere
else
the
all right so I just wanted to take this
what am I doing here
I wanted how do I get this thing
paste it and now I can say System model
plot
of that creature
now is that really what did that do the
right thing as it went to the smaller
size
should it really it should have used the
icon but I don't understand the spacing
around it Sergio
yeah that doesn't seem right
uh yeah right I can look into that
because that seems completely wrong but
it is the icon it's the thing that
presents the whole which is nice or is
there an icon no this is the diagram
is there an icon
no this is the the system model icon let
me comment that this still isn't right
you still have it is
well it doesn't look the same that is
the new progress bar
okay
okay so is this to a new system model
plot
yeah it's it's this one has no change
but what we found is that the plots in
the system modeler many of them have
legends that are sentenced long that go
off screen I said try to simulate
caption we don't have a thing called
caption
and it it just
maybe we should just gen well maybe we
should but we we don't right now
um why don't we put that into the queue
with Brett because I think that's an
interesting thing to talk about
yeah we could
yes that's fine
but remember we talked about the lesion
of things so here's one thing that we
needed to deal with Illusions so Sergio
do you have I I really wish you had had
examples ready made here
um
to have this discussion
give me a second
and
often for these variables the ending of
them is significant that's what's unique
the prefix I remember the issue right
okay let's just before we run out of
time System model measurements what is
that that is a new function
okay so if I if I take this for example
and I say System model measurements
actually you could do that yeah
uh well it doesn't have the inputs
come on guys
yep
yeah yeah
so what do I do I say System model
simulate first
well then okay no no so Stephen do you
need to understand what measurements
does
it's a particular instance right
so I could take this are you going to
listen or not listen not really I'm just
going to try it first
after I tried it I was gonna listen
okay did I did I do the right thing I
mean in other words it was a particular
instance of this model is that correct
or is that not correct
uh right so here you use like a way
around so it's that like the third use
case of systemr measurements where you
pass simulation data and then you
measured all the simulation data
okay
so is this what you expected it to do
roughly
uh yes
that's an awful lot of digits here seems
kind of crazy
I don't understand what any of this is
um but maybe I'm sure you're willing to
listen yes I'll now listen
okay maybe we can bring the page up yes
that's what I was thinking of doing
um
it's in the source okay
so
what this is for is for systems to take
input yep and generate outputs yep and
so one way to understand a system is to
send a standard signal in and see what
it responds with and a typical thing is
to send a step and see how quickly the
system responds yep
and then you can measure various
qualitative things around that so that
will measure qualitative and
quantitative performance
uh properties of the system
so if you go down there is a basically a
standard set about 10 10 of these so let
me just understand something here I mean
so like classifier measurements for
example
takes
a classifier that has been trained
but it doesn't look at specific inputs a
specific input to that classifier that's
yet another function this is again
looking at some kind of impulse response
or something step-by-step response yeah
um
and again it does it in a disembodied
way it's not saying given a particular I
mean this case here I did a particular
simulation
but but what you're saying is this I
mean what you're saying it doesn't make
a lot of sense you know actually it does
take simulation data
but the things that it measures doesn't
make a lot of sense apply to that
simulation I get it I get it because
what it's doing is taking the raw system
and asking how does it respond you know
what is its response to a step
as opposed to saying the specifics of
the system was was kicked in this way
and what happened when it was kicked in
that particular way
yeah um
so why is this not called something like
step response
I mean to me this seems like a very
general
I mean we already have that we have a
system response
but what you want is the actual numbers
the response to look at the plot
is fine but then you have to kind of
measure in the plot you know you have to
bring out your okay fine fine but so is
this analogous to classifier
measurements
in terms of what it's doing
um I mean it's just a bunch of
measurements a classifier measurements
are trying to
give you qualitative uh somewhat alone
yeah somewhat done well but look
classified measurements is taking a
function which is the classifier
function and it's telling you sort of
meta information about the classifier
function well it's trying to tell you
how good or bad it is basically right
and so and this is trying to tell you
how good about it is
right but I'm just trying to understand
the system thing that you put into this
what what is that system thing generally
is that a system that you put in or what
what do you put in here a system
which is what I thought I had here but
apparently I didn't have enough of a
system to put it in but it needs to have
an input because it can't send an input
to it if it doesn't take an input
oh I see this system has no input that's
your point right okay yes I get it I
understand so it's a system with an
input just like a classifier is a thing
with an input namely the thing supposed
to be classifying and this is now going
to feed a test a test input in and see
what happens and tell you the results
that basically correct
yes so for instance you sometimes you
you have this in everyday life like so
for instance if you go buy a car it
might have a zero to sixty time
yep
right that's basically rise time
okay here
okay but you can have the same thing for
any dynamic system there's a performance
characterization for any dynamic system
often a controller will give you kind of
better performance that's its goal
that's
is that that's not specific to this
system or can I look inside this system
and find out if you looked inside the
system you would see that someone came
up with those names that are there okay
fine all right okay
yeah
okay and these are derivatives of that
is that right
uh yes
I mean this looks like a deep
engineering
kind of I mean this is this is well I
mean I think
yeah I I mean I wouldn't say that it's
in a first in a basic control class you
need to know what the performance is how
fast is your disk drive moving that's
that's part of how you measure
measure systems I know this lingo and so
on and the way this is set up is sort of
analogous to in statistics it might be
you know an anova table or something you
know what I'm saying it's one of these
things where somebody defined this
particular joke by its numbers and now
people are using that you know it's a
little bit more fundamental Anova is
kind of a very special
method if you like for categorical data
yeah but this is kind of
kind of more like saying a predictor and
okay but this type of thing like a rise
time for example I mean could we decide
that we have a bezel function and say
what is the rise time of the vessel
function is that well defined why not
what is the right is that how is it the
rice that if you go there you can read
it in this page that we have written for
you
okay
where is it
rise time
I think that's well defined for a Bessel
function
it's like a quantify or something I mean
at the time does it have a fine the
bezel function doesn't have a final
value I mean it gets unbounded right
that choose zero the wheels around zero
but but I see so this is
but I mean this type of thing is a is a
you know
in a sense you could take any function
any interpolating function or whatever
else and these are
not statistical but they are sort of
they're features of the function that
you could extract right and that's
exactly what Sergio does when you fed it
functions when you said it's the
simulation data it has literally
functions and that's what he computes
from
but I'm saying it sure you can compute
it but doesn't have super much meaning
because it's not by the way just as a
practical matter those functions that
you have that compute rise time given
this you know interpolating function
whatever it is you should put those in
the function Repository
as separate factored functions see what
I'm saying
does that make sense
Sergio
uh okay but
um right yes I mean it's just taking it
Taking given an interpolating function
or taken out a function we could
probably run just run interpolation and
compute it from there yeah I'm just
I'm just this is the thing that we're
now
you know trying to do is these these
specialized pseudo internal things
that occasionally one will need just put
them in the function repository they
don't have to be you know they don't
have to have the same design standards
as but that's just useful
um
here so you complained Stephen last time
I was like how am I designing a
controller when I have to give these
weights and polls and it's like I don't
know how to do it yep okay wouldn't it
be nice if you can get these
specifications instead
this is the actual performance I want
yes
right isn't that wouldn't that be nice
to actually say what it is you want
well I mean look I I'm saying what I
want in a very specific engineering
clipboard kind of way I mean it's hardly
as if I'm saying you know one could
imagine some sort of arbitrary function
that says I want it to be within this
and I want to take the integral of that
and blah blah blah blah but you're
saying 90 of the final value is this and
so on I mean so it's very it's a very
specific engineering criteria which is
fine and no doubt the right thing I mean
that's the stack that's been built in
that area of engineering you know
somebody could have picked five percent
to 95 but they the fact you can modify
it if you want at the very bottom
they're method settings so you can
modify all these
okay fine okay wow so I could pay five
percent to 95 that's cool you're good
yeah yes but I mean I I think that um uh
I mean the challenge here
is a challenge that we often face which
is you know this is a specialized area
with a huge stack of you know 50 years
more than that 70 years probably of um
I've sort of made a little yeah about
about 70 to 80 years I've sort of built
up
sort of convention
and
you know it makes no sense for us to
Buck that trend
because 95 of people are going to use
this are going to know those conventions
on the other hand it is tricky because
you know it's a specialized area it's
not going to fit in very well
you know it's not going to fit in
smoothly
you know I have no idea whether people
in econometrics for example they may be
using stuff directly from Control
Systems I don't know you know they do
once when somebody yeah I mean let's
let's wonder whether somebody was was
thinking to themselves when they decided
to change the interest rate oh I wonder
what's the um you know uh settling time
will be they probably have a different
meaning for settling time in that field
but but you know you know what I'm
saying I mean I don't know whether this
is no that is actually happening they
you know things like that are studied
and used in fact with the same lingo as
Control Systems is what you're saying
yeah yeah
because you know we know perfectly well
if we went between
oh I don't know
what so for instance you know so you see
that big uh you see that that with the
bump where the the uh you see the icon
on the left column here it's the same
curve all along right we just point out
different features now do you see that
first bump when it shoots over that's
called an overshoot all right so I sort
of guessed yes okay okay and the first
one when it bumps below it's called an
undershoot okay okay
and so us just as an aside when you run
when you drive when you do you know how
to bicycle
of course I do you think okay played an
ordinary bicycle yes that part I I've
known for for a a very long time but
yeah you never know okay I've never seen
you on one so so you know a new bicycle
bicycle has this Behavior where it
creates an undershoot first so if you
want to steer right you start by
steering left
I have noticed that yeah yeah it's
called a non-minimum phase system okay
that makes it that's part of what makes
it hard to ride a bike
Minnie says
sorry is it more stable if you do that
no it's just the way that that system it
has a
it has a zero
um in the
uh right half plane
um and so that's just the way the
Dynamics of that system behaves okay
yeah
um
yeah
and
uh you know the overshoot so so for
instance now with interest rate it could
be that we're hiking interest so it's
now so much that he overshoots because
he wants a fast reaction
right
and that's that always happens for these
Dynamic systems when you wanted to
behave really rapidly you typically end
up getting an overshoot like that and
sometimes that's bad
um I mean it could be bad for the
economy if the overshoot is too big
um
yeah it's like riots and things you know
and that's right
right but but in Technical Systems like
let's say that those are two steel
rollers and you push them together to
you know let's say roll Steel Cold roll
steel if you push them together with too
much of an overshoot they will destroy
each other
yes Mr chair I'm saying and you'll have
steel pieces flying all over yeah that's
bad right yeah so so many of these are
safety critical systems like for an
airline like a Boeing 737 Max jet for
instance or something
okay you won't
no I mean this is all interesting but I
I guess my
ah yeah
I mean look this is just you know it's
an area I don't know I'm gonna I'm not
done with the illustration I think it's
too detailed to just I'm going to
iterate on that it's like too much bad
it's not too bad
I mean I think I understand what's going
on here
I mean of course I don't know you know
if the thing had an essential
Singularity here I don't know how to
classify its overshoot but I think
you're you know you're making a stack of
assumptions that mean there is no
essential Singularity there
actually I said early on and that's
another concept we're going to have to
introduce in our system that this
concept only makes sense for uh stable
systems the stable here means bounded
input generates bounded output
I see
so that's called Bible stability and
many kinds of stability
well it's interesting I mean I you know
I don't have a sense here of
you know
one thing I'm curious about and then we
should should wrap up this segment
um
you know if I'm out and about and I'm
trying to design actual control systems
for
[Music]
um
what will be an example I don't know
there seemed to be a moment
you know the moment of the Segway and
things like that seemed to be a moment
where people were you know very big on
exotic control systems but I suppose
with the drones and things like that
there are plenty of interesting slightly
there's always new areas for control
autonomous cars it's a popular one now
right fair enough okay so
so let's uh yeah optimize energy use in
a data center was one that came in from
Facebook group yesterday which is
perfect for us
the
so I mean
okay but so what I'm asking is
the the apparatus that we have now
how
you know is it usable in practice for
the typical problem
is it yeah yes how far have we got
no it is usable for the typical problem
um
I think our modeling our modeling
capabilities is second to none this is
the best in the world with system
modeler
our control systems
I would say is
is okay
uh
uh could do with some more kind of
TLC we have some capabilities of
automatically generate implementations
with microcontroller kits right
um so we have kind of a full stack from
modeling to deployment in a way and just
a general knowledge question I mean you
know traditional control systems with
all of their sort of polynomial oriented
stuff
how do they stack up I mean is is and I
know that um uh you know reinforcement
learning is fairly similar to a bunch of
this control system stuff but I'm just
curious whether whether you know inject
a neural net and all be better or is it
irrelevant or what well uh
Okay so
in reinforcement learning
what you have is an environment
in control system what you have is a
plant
okay plant and environment is the same
thing yep they're just two different
groups naming things yep
the the standard example that people
proudly show for reinforcement learning
that is more classical control which is
an inverted pendulum it's it's not it's
not very good it's like outright lousy
but reinforcement learning is very
impressive for things
you know um things the control system
doesn't really apply to there is no like
you don't do control systems for chess
playing or go play
yeah that's what I'm saying those are
domains that it doesn't really deal with
it
no I understand mathematical object
rather than a computational you mean it
needs differential equations
yeah
as opposed to a discrete program of some
kind program in the sense of
um
um
but exactly yes but the methods that are
being used
in reinforcement learning for sort of
discrete
stuff I mean because the neural Nets are
not that discreet you know they've got
continuous weights and all kinds of
things in them
yes
and
it's possible but I haven't seen it yet
um and maybe someone here knows of a of
an instance
uh you know in principle like most of
the standard control design procedures
use linear controllers
you know and they look look at the
linearization of the system there's some
things to go beyond that for sure but
that's mostly what they do
a non-linear controller of course
includes a linear controller yep
so if the way that you compute them was
effective and efficient
it should always be able to do better
yeah I hope so just go I mean it's like
it's like you know doing linear
programming versus doing arbitrary
optimization I mean yeah yeah you can
some of them you can really do
systematically and others are just
flapping around exactly
but so but the thing I'm just trying to
understand is is
you know like like a modern
you know random modern drone or
something like this
yeah is its controller
you're saying the controllers there are
are essentially classical controllers
maybe they're using something oh
absolutely oh yeah
yeah like the motor controllers and so
on are absolutely standard classical
controllers no question
okay but the basis functions so to speak
that you're saying if you know like I
remember I happened to see the very
first demo of the you know oh we can
play video games with a you know
reinforcement learning type thing
um yeah
you're saying that
in
that the apparatus that it is not the
case that there is a plug-in module that
fits into the workflow that you've
defined for controller design is it the
case that there's a plug-in module that
is different that happens to work for
8-bit discrete video games but the
workflow is the same or is the workflow
different for that
it's so much I mean the control systems
that we have is basically linear I mean
we have a little bit beyond that
and so it assumes that you have these
mathematical models but the stuff that I
worked on for instance before doesn't
assume that at all it has a way more
General
kind of framework in which case you can
you can actually Define I didn't call
them reinforcement learning but that's
what they were and they did play games
and and things like your Boolean
function stuff is that what you're
talking about
yeah well that that was that was kind of
very discreet stuff but I did something
like a Tetris controller that plays
Tetris games optimally plays Tetris
games and beats everyone
and you can formulate that I formulated
that as optimal control
but what was the sort of basis thing
that I mean you know you got
differential equations but most of the
stuff that's going on here what was the
sort of basic function that was inside
the tetris controller
it was a computational framework so
there's basically there is a the
Dynamics of the Tetris game is that
there is a new piece coming in
yep you make an action you you the
player you know you're going to move it
the the piece left and right rotate it
and drop it
and that means that you update the state
of the game
I understand but your internal
representation for what you're showing
here on the screen the internal
representation of everything is going to
be differential equations
yes yeah here yes but in the tetris
controller it's just a dynamic system
it's a fine it's basically a state it's
a dynamic system where you update the
state the state of a Tetris game is the
tetris board
when you say State you mean like a final
automata that kind of state well it
happens in Tetris that it is a finite
automaton with a big number of states
but but it is a finite determine okay
but I mean what you're saying we should
move to a different topic but I mean
what you're saying is there's a oh I'm
representing it as a system of of you
know differential equations
now
you know I would assume when you have
differential equations and you have daes
and things and you have events and so on
and the differential equations that that
is sliding towards the finite automata
because presumably you could represent a
final automaton by a collection of sort
of event
type
you know you'd be wasting your
differential equations because most of
the you know it would just be constants
and then the events
or am I wrong yeah well you can't it's a
longer discussion but so let's take your
drone case
I mean the motors the electro
electromagnetics
electromechanical systems to run the
motors and stuff that's actually well
modeled with differential equations and
well controlled at that level but think
of the Drone there's a higher level
the macro level control of the Drone
where you basically basically build a
computer interface where you move from
waypoints and you have higher level
commands
that's typically done in a discrete
fashion
yeah do you understand so there's no
level controllers or are these you know
closer to the physics the higher level
controllers are sort of more you know
cyber more information Theory
and that's done for many things you know
think of a you know cars I'm just trying
to understand the mechanics inside here
because I mean we've got something here
which is a differential equation based
you know undershoots and overshoots and
so on clearly undershoots and overshoots
aren't terribly relevant if you've got a
fan of automata that you're trying to
deal with here obviously not right so
I'm trying to understand is is there
what is the level of unification or not
of the kind of you know of what you know
what is the analogous thing that you
would deal with in a financial automaton
and is this workflow that you're
defining here with it's not quite the
same it's the same if you if you back
off a little bit they're both dynamic
system like you have state equations for
differential equations or difference
equations and you have the same thing
when you have finite automata
but so in particular System model
measurements is it relevant for the
financial it's not relevant no it's not
relevant and it's the same thing as
not relevant
sorry does its name tell us that it's
not relevant that's what I'm kind of
complaining about here oh oh
um
I think that this is the general
understanding of what system modeler and
system modeling does for us
General understanding excludes the final
automata yes
okay
okay
I mean you know I think it's a a on a
multi-decade time scale it's probably a
different story but but um probably yes
but
okay
all right anyway we should move on all
right well this is this is cool it's
interesting I learned a little bit every
time we talk about this I learned a tiny
bit more
um all right I think we should move to
our next topic if that's okay okay
all right thank you sir Joe Suga
thank you good stuff thank you bye
okay
and our next topic let's see the
material for it is where
this is Charles on graphs and geometry
and our material is in the calendar I
hope
I mean I sent it to your calendar people
yes it is in the calendar
okay
we are changing topic altogether all
right
faster
Graf blasts well okay
is that a library that exists for sort
of is that uh library that goes across
Intel and arm and everything or is that
what is that
Charles Jones
yeah so God bless his
pretty much a framework similar to
um you know blast library on linear
algebra no I I know but I mean you know
mkl or something is a is a fancy
implementation of blast and I'm just
asking is this something where they've
been fancy implementations across
multiple Hardware architectures
um yes people are still lucky on it like
you say like Intel have you know they're
adding actually some of those modules in
nkl right now but they're still living
so we've we Intel have started in on it
we started working with Intel several
years ago where they got interested in
graph Primitives to basically extend mkl
for with graph Primitives because it's
to a large extent a linear algebra
problem graph theory is basically linear
algebra
cool
what about graph layout
is that something that's going to be
supported by functions in there no no
that's a separate thing
that's a shame that seems like a very
gpuable kind of microcodable type of
thing yeah the difference is that graph
layout is basically an optimization
problem
these are lower level kinds of things
where they try to make it you know
really these are like linear algebra
direct you know kind of uh direct
problems basically basically dot
products yeah I don't care much about
those two but these are useful because
these I've noticed are quite slow like
we could connect to components so that's
about to get a lot faster is that
correct so what person when you say slow
they are not Percy slow even if you look
at the Benchmark we are no I know I'm
not saying Charles that we are doing it
slowly I'm just saying that when I have
a very big graph it takes a while
since yeah so we were worried so you
know we've been monitoring this for a
while
part of what we found was that you know
um we are pretty good already
we got some improvement but not as
dramatic as we feared or hoped
this 13.2 here is this inverse speeds
because this is slower here
um well so when we say 30.3 shop
actually Market that means the the LA
graph and Telegraph framework so I'm
sorry what
so this one is is using the the new
framework the graph glass framework the
13.2 it will not be in the system I
think it's just a label which we should
fix right so right now in the system for
example we'll have page rank where you
know if you look at the first bar chart
it kind of show the
a good Improvement when you get to the
range of you know 30 million edges and
such
okay great
but in terms of connected components we
you know there won't be any change in
the system I think we because it's in
fact slower because the graph blast is
slower than what we already have right
sad
because that's sad yeah but so the fact
is that this is happening and we are
we're kind of on it and so we're you
know we're running competitive
benchmarks if it turns out to be faster
we'll switch and turn those things well
there's anything you should also give
that feedback to the folks like they
didn't tell and so on who are developing
this because right
um because hopefully they can make it
faster
um
okay breadth first scan is a mess as we
all know
this doesn't deal with the design of it
I'm well aware I'm just saying I you're
saying it's faster or is it is it also
no so that was also one which we we want
plug it in is not faster okay this is a
bit of an anti-climax here because the
functions are the faster ones I don't
really care about
um
okay sad well I mean we were hoping yeah
I understand it's a reasonable hope
um
okay fine go ahead
but I say it's a continuous work right
we're keeping you know monitoring
ourselves kind of improve that and do
Benchmark and see what we can it was a
reasonable bet that just didn't work out
okay fine shortest tour that's that's
the additional that's these Arrow
uh element to these things here right
right
design of
well you should probably look at the
function of the fat new but that's yeah
look look fine through this path new new
oh wow find shortest two are new yeah
like that yeah yes
that will be you know but it's when you
do too many changes it's just it's like
scaffolding everything
okay
those are the ones that you I think they
came from you Stephen yep look good to
me what else do you want to show here
that's it great
okay geometry
so there have been some improvement in
important export and one does the
example is we added you know support of
vertex normal and vertex color so they
see that process of the preserving
Fidelity when we import the export
elements so that's good that's been an
issue with that was an issue with 3D
scanners right
would scan and then the thing would be
white when it came in for us that's what
triggered it actually in fact okay
honestly several years ago that happened
to me a few open examples you can
probably see it motion
no but yeah there well we're there where
your mouse was
this one here there yeah
okay
Spidey
is now fully available
right
um
okay
okay
we had a huge Dragon deficit that we
needed to cure
you know okay we'll go out
why is this so unbelievably slow
is it huge
um yes the number of polygon is huge
but it's decent when it loads I mean the
front end is responsive so
it's just that I'm kind of making a joke
right but these are standard examples no
I understand that and I'm I'm just
wondering about the why
I see that's the rotation controller and
then it jumps to that configuration
okay
so you've scanned a bunch of objects
yourselves
yeah we ran into a bunch of problems and
I wanted us to scan insects for instance
um
and so that's part of what we want to
show at the conference you know we have
this new handheld scanner oh you know
Brad clear I believe has a big
collection of beetles
oh really and insects he's got did you
hear that Charles
yes
go let's get his beetles
but they have all kinds of iridescent
whatever that won't be well scanned with
ordinary colors
Oh I'm great
but that's that's amusing I mean I
assume you'll do game pieces and things
like chess pieces and so on
yes we could if we should I mean part of
what we wanted to to kind of simplify
workflows here and so this is part of
what improvements that you see up there
with supporting color and vertex I don't
know why this font is so terrible there
but
um
but so okay so these things were scanned
uh
why is Miss Mulan not not oh it's just
an image
if you put the message get too big in a
notebook but we just put images
faster I see I say okay fine
but so what are we scanning and why I
mean are we trying to get some canonical
collection of things or are these just
examples
actually wanted to get kind of a
canonical examples to indicate sort of
uh what people can and should do in
terms of create geometric models from
everyday life we wanted to make the
workflow from everyday natural natural
and everyday objects to geometric models
and compute
yeah I guess
yeah okay I mean because we've been
working on geometric reconstruction
right and so we want to make sure that
the full workflow is there and you know
go from objects into wild weather it's
natural man-made or man-made
to uh and a you know as a way of
modeling basically
yes I mean these are rather
Whimsical kinds of things yes I know
I mean
to me
you know if I think about you know if
I'm going to describe to people 3D
objects okay
you know I don't know
a the things that I might use as a as a
language for saying it's shaped like a
such and such
it's shaped like a coffee mug it's
shaped like a you know uh I don't know a
an air pod it's shaped like you know
what I'm saying there's a certain
um
there's certain
sort of set of
of kind of and yet I would never say
it's shaped like a wood frog because I
have no idea what that is like
I'm saying I mean in in um uh I mean
some of these
don't movies like it doesn't like Toy
Story I I don't didn't they have you
know 3D objects like this they probably
have kind of a canonical set that um uh
you know back from sort of the world of
computer Graphics
um were things that were kind of um
uh you know shaped things or something
anyway just just some thoughts
I'm not quite sure what they're trying
to achieve here but
we want variety of ways of creating
geometry so one is that for instance you
search web geometry search we didn't
have it ready for now but we you know
intend to have it where you look at
repositories of ready-made things that
you can start from you look at a world
around you can you scan it if the
scanners are cheap enough maybe that's a
way to get the geometric model so let me
ask you I mean we have a construction
modeling language right
your random iPhone will scan stuff I
mean I've done it like twice I know and
I I mean what is the format that that
comes out in and and can we read it yes
we can read it so this is where I think
we need to kind of write it in US
writing another app for the iPhone we
want to use the app that we have
you know
um Wolfram for iPhone
you know from language for iPhone a
Mathematica for iPhone or mobile and
that would be a super good thing for us
to get there
so we should use that app we should
trigger it from our app there
get the data hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on let's remind you how
this works okay normally well just
reminding you how this works I mean
right now for example we have a form
function mechanism and our form function
mechanism right if if you want a
a photograph from a from a phone right
you can do that by deploying a form
getting the photograph you know taking
the picture goes to the cloud who loaded
it
but nobody should have to write the form
to get the [ __ ] picture or a 3D model
that seems ridiculous well no but Roger
Roger you don't have to okay so let's go
through the workflow for one second
okay
the problem is
you've got your I mean
if if you have a URL
that you click on right on your phone or
you're clicking on it through the
browser on your phone that's one thing
we've also got a Cloud app
right that's
but we also have a mobile app
we are on the phone
no we don't we have a MOBA yes we do
well we have we have the player app we
have the player app player app doesn't
have input
the player app is a reader only it's
good but it's a reader only
it takes a notebook look the workflow
you're describing okay I had a design
for the workflow you're describing it
was a single client value
okay we've never quite implemented that
and I think it's a fine thing to talk
about but we should go through it I
think in one we wanted to go both ways
actually so
for the scanning thing that we talk
about now I want to be able to use the
iPhone scanner the lighter that's built
into that
uh get the point Cloud yes and or get
the reconstructed server yes exactly
okay so listen and we shouldn't go
through this in detail now this client
value design was all about that okay so
my typical example was magnetometer
there are different things you want to
do you want the instantaneous value you
want to record some you know trace and
then read it in there are a variety of
different things you want to do with it
so client value was a mechanism where
you could say from a desktop product or
whatever else you're communicating
through the cloud because you have to
have some way to communicate to the
phone right the phone doesn't naturally
you know uh you know you you communic I
mean that that's a that's a way to
communicate to it and then the client
value thing is pulling back something
from the client namely the phone
in some modality
but you could do it the other way too
our app you can one of the we could give
it a better Mission you know like if you
want to scan something you could do it
from our app it's one of those things
you could I know I know and then it can
post it
oh you're not triggering it from a
desktop Roger Roger yes you're right
okay let me give an example of another
case where that's been done you know the
Wolfram Alpha app just recently started
doing math OCR
okay right so that's a case where you
are using you know we can't do that we
don't do that on the on a desktop web
browser at this time we only do it in
the The Client app on the phone
yeah perfect okay quite a bit of thought
has gone into this particular type of
issue you've got an interesting use case
let's talk about it I've worked on this
extensively unfortunately we never got
client value implemented which would
have been the framework that would just
immediately have worked for what you
want
okay I have another one for you which is
that wouldn't it be nice if you create
you know 3D shapes
you can push it
to your client app you know our mobile
Mathematica
and now we can use the AR core AR I know
I understand you can walk around the
object great I'm glad you're thinking
about this stuff let's do a meeting
about this topic it's got quite
different people in it
um you know let's get such a meeting
it'll be a good it'll be a good
discussion
you know because again we've got pieces
of this we never quite got to the point
I mean you know there are things like
for example our chemical drawing front
end is another example where again it's
somewhat different stuff that you feed
in that's not so much for phones
Etc et cetera et cetera there's lots of
cases of this they were all attempted to
be unified in this client value
mechanism but we never managed to get it
built because the use cases didn't quite
reach the point where you know we really
felt we should do it all right I think
we have to move to a different topic
here oh you've got something else here
what is this
blurring
so if you go to the source the the
reference page it's another effect
along with what along with drop shadow
oh boy
in 2005 so we are only 17 years late
um
I want to be drawn
typo
so this so its only friend is drop
shadowing is that correct well it's
gonna get hallowing too but
the Halloween we wanted for
what is Halloween text
on maps
what is Halloween
Halloween is a kind of a highlight where
you draw a Hello around an object
I see
okay
well I mean
I don't think the name is that terrible
that's all right
any any further comments about this
no not really no
okay
I don't think blurring effect would have
been anything better I don't think it
helps
no it just gives you
mental bucket in which it fits yeah a
little bit all right I think we have to
move to a different topic here
okay very much guys okay thank you bye
bye okay we are now turning to astronomy
Etc and the agenda is where
it's in the calendar invite okay
okay
um I think we we passed units and dates
and we passed trees
so in the previous meeting you have had
a quick look at Astra position
and we wanted to understand better the
structure of our commands and the
various freedoms it has Etc
are we realistically going to be able to
cover this right now I mean we've only
got a few minutes this seems like a
difficult one is there may be other
stuff we could look at here
um and then come back to Astro in a
separate custom meeting or do you think
we can cover it quickly
um I think we can have a quick look at
the Astro position astrographics would
require certainly a a separate meeting
so perhaps you can have a look at the at
the
definition box the notes and see how you
think a faster position yes okay
this is an object with match
Freedom so
um are those in units as with an
altitude are they just if you're just
given us plain integer so they assume to
be in degrees or what
so that's one of the things to discuss
at the moment I'm using Radiance but I
think I'm I'm we should change the
degrees I don't think anybody uses
Radiance for this
is that true I mean if you look at the
um
I mean I I think it'd be like saying we
can specify you know the the um
the latitude on the earth with radians
nobody would ever do it now we're
talking on the input or on output
because on input the user might input
several different possible numbers and
they might assume that it's either
degrees or hours of right Ascension or
something else but on output we could
always standardize to something so which
one are we talking about here
so in input you can always use
quantities to specify what you want and
that will understood that will be
understood so what Stephen was asking is
if you write a number how is it
interpreted and um as I said I'm using I
was using radius because to avoid the
computation because I wanted to to test
the the performance of this but I think
we have to
yeah it would be nicer if it's decreased
I think it should be degrees Yeah it's
just numbers I think that's correct yep
so then
yeah what units is r
exactly so are there I'm using
astronomical units and I think this is
the most useful I agree I can't imagine
anything other than that I mean in
you know and the solar system definitely
outside the solar system of course you
know it's going to be very large numbers
for Aus but
yeah well when you introduce
quantitative objects in news light years
or parsecs or whatever
exactly did you reduce quantities yeah
yeah it doesn't it right if you're just
going to use numbers then we have to
pick one it's not going to be right for
everything a used is fine as anything
else I guess I just wanted to raise the
issue yep
yeah
exactly now there is a difficult thing
here which is what's the celestial
sphere
because implicitly should be Infinity
but hold on hold on hold on yeah but I
use I mean for satellites are you using
you know in the case of Geo position
we're using meters yep for the altitude
are we sure that this isn't going to end
up being used for satellite stuff where
it's better to use meters than
astronomical units
I don't know I mean astronomical units
is pretty weird for a satellite it it is
but we can choose only one and and I
think it's the most appropriate for
planets which is one of the most
interesting things here
yeah yeah it should either be meters or
au's you know meters is going to be big
all the time
but it's more you know SI unit e
um yeah we're going with degrees anyway
so which has been to your position we're
going with degrees and meters
okay but anyway let's talk about the
celestial sphere so meters is fine yes
so the problem is that oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait are we going to go with
meters or are we going to go I was
saying that meters would also be fine
but I I do prefer astronomical units
yeah
fine that can be the default because
it's just a pure number yep
okay so so the celestial sphere the the
main point here is that these will take
like Astro position an array of of
triples or numbers of two points
and so if we put Infinity there it will
not be packable
so just because of that
what I'm using is a number which is huge
so something like 10 to 16 to represent
uh
is larger than the than the radius of
the universe
this is a hack I mean
it's a hack that you think is not going
to blow up because the universe is only
of finite size
yes and because this is always hidden
behind a summary box do not see those
numbers
but this allows packing without packing
fine fine but I mean the fact is the
fact the inability of packing to deal
with you know Infinities and a lot of
numbers and things is the thing that
should be fixed independent of this
although it's not going to be fixed on a
time scale that we need for this so I I
don't disagree that you know it's a
reasonable hack to use a number bigger
than the size of the universe what's
with 10 to the 16 doing it in 2016 Aus
is bigger than the size of the universe
but yes but you need to go to you know
10 to the 30 meters or something to be
bigger than the size of the universe
so that's another argument for a use I
suppose
right um what a hack I mean it's
disgusting but yes
um it is so the other possibility I
consider is to store parallaxes which
are one over reduce and then the the
celestial sphere becomes zero
but most people will be confused by
parallaxes
well they may or may not see them but
but yeah no I think that I think
look I think
the correct solution to this is to fix
packing but that's a longer term thing
but we should at least initiate the
discussion of fixing packing
okay anyway I mean that's a hack I you
know I hope we don't have to hear about
it again type thing I mean it's just
horrifying but it's okay
um
all right so what else to know about
this
so so then we have the second argument
about frames and the frames are the
orientation stuff
and and they have a default so if you
specify aquatorial frame or ecliptic
frame there are many other lists below
what is the default
the default is Horizon which means it's
your uh um where you are so it's what
the sky will look like from where you
are as a myth and altitude from your
location right now so like sun position
so to be clear the return of sun
Position will be consistent with astral
position of the sun is that correct
yep
so what does sun position actually
return right now it returns in altitude
hasn't it doesn't it yes yes it does by
default which way around
uh it's a it's um yes it's um at the
altitude yeah and I'm using the same
conventional here which is the opposite
to to Geo so we are putting first
longitude and then latitudes
yes
the Sun is setting in the east
setting in the west rather sorry and um
it's it's fairly close to the Horizon
now
um
okay that's cool so then okay so that's
the default
so that's a frame that's a horizon frame
different from these frames right yep
and these are frames that's frame fixed
to the Earth that's a frame fixed the
solar system that's a frame fixed the
Galaxy correct
uh well yes but the origin is is tricky
so the equatorial and ecliptic are
centered at this at the earth center in
the galactic disappointed
sorry Copernicus would be disappointed
we can create more but and the galactic
for example the standard thing is to fix
the galactic frame at the center of the
solar system
I see
okay so that's explained uh in the list
below
so I mean there must be a coordinate
system in which it's Central Center of
the Sun and though things like that
right did you can always specify
location goes to
ice and and choose your Center but they
all have a default just in case you
don't say anything
right and since we are currently an
earth-dwelling species it's probably
this is a good default
I mean it's centered at the center of
the earth for Equatorial is that right
yes
and ecliptic
right
so we visualized the ecliptic as the
orbit of the sun around the earth and
not vice versa
as I said Copernicus will be
disappointed yes
500 years later it's still not changed
actually
um
anyway
the
um
right and then the third argument is a
coordinate system
which says do you want spherical
coordinates or cylindrical or Cartesian
or a projection
or projection yeah you can put that more
wider and it would take the spherical
coordinates and project them
so in that case you are conflating
geogrid position and geoposition in some
sense is that right yes actually the
four of them the E and U and the XYZ are
also here
but so what in the case of Geo is a pure
spherical position
and we've got a separate grid position
thing which is the projected positions
in this case astral position is also
representing the the projected positions
great because this gives more power for
example we don't have a Geo cylindrica
while the here we can put cylindric on
the third argument or in geoposition we
have the opposition e and U but
astronomers sometimes use s e u I see
and so there are all these possibilities
can be described here
okay
well it's very cool
it's a big super function
and then the frame has parameters so it
works like projection
so there are all these frames by default
how do you get a list of all the frames
uh well they are there in those three
groups the inertial frames which means
they don't move
they don't rotate in time yeah the icrs
the j2000 ETC no I understand but I mean
I'm just asking if you want to get I I'm
just saying one of the mechanisms that
we need to be introducing is when
there's a whole collection of
possibilities in a function like this we
should have a data repository entry
which simply lists all of these and we
should reference it in the documentation
just because otherwise you know
otherwise you're scraping the document
let's say I wanted to just sample all
the frames I don't know why exactly but
let's say I wanted to sample all of them
let's say I was making some piece of
documentation or some demo or something
like that and I want to get a list of
the frames it's like oh my gosh I'm
going to have to scrape the
documentation to get that mm-hmm
shouldn't we think of something more
built in than a data you know
they're separate they likely to diverge
anyway no but that I mean the question
of how it sounds like a discovery
mechanism yeah it is a discovery
mechanism but I think it's messy and I
think some of these are pretty
you know I think that's a good place to
put it initially I think that the I've
looked at this in thinking about you
know we can use the entity system for
this I mean maybe we should be using
Wolfram language data somehow for this
the geoprecedent is geoprojection data
and geodesy data foreign
Styles and things as separate functions
I I'm pretty unconvinced I think we need
a general mechanism and possibly the
general mechanism should be through the
Entity framework look I think this is
again it's a separate discussion I think
it reminds me of other things like
dollar import formulas dollar export
form I know I know I know yes I know
we've got six different mechanisms for
the same idea yeah but I mean it would
be useful to to have a mechanism that
lists the defaults
yeah okay let's get a separate meeting
to talk about this
I don't know what to be called exactly
but
um all right and then there there are
these parameters so these parameters are
where the physics
um is is hidden
so we can say use this Frame but with
aberration or without aberration
considering these mutation model or that
other one yeah right
I'd love to talk about this but I think
I should go to a different meeting okay
so what let's let's plan to have another
iteration here
um
maybe we schedule an hour for the
residents I think we should yes okay
all right wonderful stuff okay
children okay